le samedi 19 décembre les autorités
sanitaires britanniques confinait
londres et le sud-est du pays
en cause la propagation d'une nouvelle
variante du virus
comme tous ses congénères le virus
ascough de a connu de très nombreuses
mutations plusieurs dizaines de milliers
depuis le début de l'épidémie
la plupart sont sans conséquence sur la
nature du virus mais certaines sont
source de modifications plus importantes
par exemple la première souche du virus
est différente de celle qui s'est depuis
répandue à travers la planète
dans de nombreux cas les mutations
touchent les pointes du virus grâce
auquel ce dernier infecte les cellules
humaines
c'est également ce qui s'est produit
avec le variant britannique
ce nouveau ca skov 2 s'impose rapidement
parmi la population contaminée et serait
50 à 74 % plus infectieux et c'est bien
ce qui inquiète les autorités
européennes
en revanche aucun changement dans la
mortalité du virus n'a été pour le
moment mesures et d'autres variantes ont
également émergé cette année comme au
nord de l'espagne
à la fin du mois de juin ou en afrique
du sud au début octobre dans les deux
cas les études sont en cours pour
déterminer la contagiosité de ces
variants une nouvelle variante vient
également d'être identifiée au nigeria
et qui présenterait des similitudes avec
le virus britannique
mais rien pour le moment n'indique que
les vaccins soient moins efficace face à
ses nouveaux seins skov 2 en revanche il
n'est pas impossible que de futurs
mutation sur ces variants amenuisent les
effets des traitements à l'avenir